Element 118, Ununoctium or Uuo,
is the last element in the Periodic Table,
and it's in the group which contains the noble gases,
going from Helium right down to radioactive Radon,
so it is going to be radioactive.
So far, only 3 Atoms, have been observed.
First one Atom then another two. So it's more than Ununquadium,
is it more? It's more than Ununquadium, where we had,
only one Atom, but  it's still not very many Atoms.
It's still arguable whether it will be a gass-like Radon,
or it may be a solid, just like some of the other elements,
perhaps a solid that's rather volatile.
So that it would evaporate easily. But nobody knows.
How can you know 118  is the last element,
on the Periodic Table? -Well formally,
they could be heavier elements than 118, but the electrons,
the negatively charged particles, that surround,
the positively charged nucleus, are in shells,
which gradually go outwards. Rather like the skins,
of an onion. So that element 118,
represents the whole of a shell, being filled.
So we know that there are no more electrons,
that can be easily accommodated and if we make element 119,
which would be an alkali metal like sodium or cesium,
then we would have to put a single electron,
a lot further away, from the nucleus.
And as soon as you start adding electrons,
that are further away, the whole system,
is expected to become very much less stable.
So if we can only make  3 Atoms of element 118,
something that's going to be very much less stable,
is not likely to be found in the short time.
Though one of the  exciting things about science,
is that the unexpected often happens.
So, it might be that before  we've started updating,
some of these videos, element 119 will be announced.
And nobody will be more excited than me.
www.periodicvideos.com University of Nottingham
Captions by www.SubPLY.com